[Music]
you guys shoot a walking dead in atlanta
and you're shooting in a lot of outdoor
locations where i'm imagining there's a
huge mosquito problem there's got to be
all kinds of insects there's everything
i mean there's these things called
velvet ants which are massive red ants
and then there's
ticks there's a lot of ticks yeah and um
i've had a run-in with a tick
uh no it was a dark alleyway
he pulled a knife that's what it sounds
like it was really bad actually i went
home after a day of work and i was doing
the regular tick check and then i wanted
to go into the shower and then i pulled
my pants down
and uh i had a guy
on my guy
you had a tick on your uh on your member
on the top on the tip of tip on the tip
on the tip oh my god i have never heard
of it i've never heard of that i've
never heard of that until i saw an
adventurous tick it was horrible
and so i remember like i was like how do
i get this off i was freaking out and i
was trying to pull it off and it was on
so tight
that i could hold the tick
and then hold me as well
i could like marionette myself wow
it was horrible so after after a couple
hours of that yeah
yeah i mean
i was practicing for a while
stephen you've been in there 15 hours
[Laughter]
it was horrible it was the worst
experience i got it off i killed it with
a flamethrower lighter flame thrower i'm
glad you took it off first yeah yeah
yeah i'm glad you weren't like
oh